A knitter was using a hand knitting
pattern that instructed her to work
left-leaning and right-leaning
double decreases.
Now, hand knitting instructions for this
type of decrease can be worded in a lot of
different ways.
Let's look at how to create these
decreases on the knitting machine.
This is a right-leaning, double decrease,.
A double decrease, just means
you're decreasing two stitches.
In this example, there are three stitches
that are knit plain along the edge of the
knitting.
Allowing these three stitches to roll.
This creates a neat
no-finish knitted edge.
The direction of the lean of the
decreases provides a decorative addition.
Notice that these stitches are leaning to
the right as you view the knitting from
the knit side
to work this on the machine, we need to
think a little bit backwards because we're
looking at the purl side of the knitting.
To work a right-leaning, double
decrease, leaving three stitches plain.
You'll transfer two stitches to the right,
putting three stitches on one needle and
then transfer the three plain stitches to
fill in those empty needles.
And be sure to take the decrease
needles to out of work position.
This is a left-leaning, double decrease,
and you'll see this more commonly.
Again, we're decreasing two stitches along
the edge of our knitting, leaving three
plain stitches.
Notice that the stitches are leaning left.
As you view the knitting from
the knit side of the work.
To work this on the machine, you'll
transfer two stitches to the left, putting
three stitches on the needle, then fill in
the emptied needles to complete the double
decrease.
Let's look at this again.
Each time you have a stack of three
stitches, the key is the first stitch in
the stack.
In other words, pay attention to the
stitch that we'll be showing on the public
side of the knitting.